right after the structure of DNA started
to be more well understood people looked
at it and scratched their hands and
thought you know it's carrying
information about life why can't it
carry any kind of information you're
listening to the Microsoft Research
podcast a show that brings you closer to
the cutting edge of technology research
and the scientists behind it
I'm your host Gretchen using as
traditional semiconductor technologies
for computer storage scaled down
everyone is looking for alternative
solutions to the growing gap between the
amount of data were capable of producing
and the amount of data were capable of
storing while some have focused on
hardware accelerators for machine
learning and others are investigating
new memory technologies dr. Karen
Strauss a senior researcher at Microsoft
Research in Redmond has been exploring
the role of biotechnology in IT via an
end-to-end system that stores digital
data in DNA on today's podcast dr.
Strauss talks about life at the
intersection of computer science and
biology which for many is more like the
intersection of science fiction and
science and explains that the unique
properties of DNA could eventually
enable us to store really big data in
really small places for a really long
time that and much more on this episode
of the Microsoft Research podcast
[Music]
Karen Strauss welcome to the podcast
thanks for having me you're a senior
researcher at MSR and an affiliate
professor in the department of computer
science and engineering at the
University of Washington you situate
your research at the intersection of
computer science systems and biology
which is a fascinating intersection
that's right that's been very exciting
how would you describe the work you do
in general terms we'll get you up in the
morning the multidisciplinarity of the
work is really exciting we are studying
how to store digital data in synthetic
DNA and really sort of bringing science
fiction into reality so it's sort of a
dream come true let's talk about this
idea of the end of Moore's law what do
you think people need to know and
understand about Moore's law that kind
of gives us a framework for why you're
doing what you're doing
Moore's law is let's say not a law but
an observation that Gordon Moore has
made that you can shrink transistors at
the certain rate every certain number of
years you have doubling on the number of
transistors so it's essentially this
observation that you get more
transistors into the same area of a
processor and so you can do more with
that over time that's based on silicon
technology and fabrication methods that
are really miniaturizing the devices
that are built with silicon therefore
giving us more of those devices
there's improving the technology so that
we can do more with the same amount of
material the same amount of silicon so
there's a point where it's too small you
can't do anymore with it precisely we're
starting to get to that point some would
argue that we've already gotten to that
point depending how you look at it those
structures that we're manufacturing are
already pretty small we're at the nano
scale and in some cases depending on the
parts of the structures and the devices
were fabricating it's just a layer of a
few atoms that are being built
there and so it's getting quite hard and
also less profitable from the scaling
perspective to really use these devices
all right so why can't he just this is
one of those crazy questions why can't
you just say sorry guys we're done for
small as we get well there's still more
technology tricks that we can play and
as long as we can play those tricks we
will but it's getting harder right it's
getting harder it's getting more
expensive and so in addition to really
continuing the process to the extent we
can people are looking at alternatives
to it it's getting harder so we need to
be smarter so we're tasked with creating
new technologies and by we I mean you
so talk for a minute just for context
about the history of data storage I mean
not like a box in a cave but digital
data would have been our technologies
and how is it evolved to where we are
now and then we'll talk about DNA in a
second sure let me start with motivation
and the trend which is the data we are
capable of generating is growing
exponentially yeah and even though the
devices that can store the data are also
growing exponentially it's different
Exponential's and so the gap between
what we are creating and what we can
store is growing and that's the trend
we're seeing that is concerning so if we
just follow the industry if today we're
capable with storing about 30 percent of
the information we generate in only 10
or 12 years we'll be able to store about
3% and then in ten more years about half
of a percent of everything that we
generate so that's a concerning trend we
think that we need a radical new
solution to address that problem now in
terms of the storage evolution right
we've had magnetic devices like tape and
hard drives and in fact you know my
first computer had 35 megabytes of
storage right over those days so this is
storage technology and then we have
memory technology so for example DRAM
that's electronic and most recently
electronic and silicon storage being
developed in flesh and SSDs so all these
different technologies they're based on
creating structures the
can then hold a bit and that's sort of
what they have in common
but the scaling of the storage
technology is also based on making these
structures smaller and so we're also
hitting limits on the storage not only
transistors but also storage
technologies are hitting the same limits
of miniaturization let's talk about DNA
or deoxyribonucleic acid you are working
on putting data digital data on DNA as a
level set what is DNA from a biological
and chemical perspective
all right so DNA is a big long molecule
it's essentially a chain of what we call
bases and that's what we describe as ATC
ng those are called monomers that put
together into a chain make up DNA each
side of that double helix is made of
complementary bases so a complements
with T on the other side and C
complements with G from an information
storage perspective we only need to look
at one of the sides the other is
redundant because there's a direct
correspondence between a to T C to G
okay so if I'm going back to my biology
class I remember DNA being framed as the
building blocks of life the molecules
that make up our genome so DNA carries
the information your genetic information
and in fact it doesn't just store
information it actually performs along
with enzymes many of the functions that
are needed for life so okay that's a
thing it exists it's already loaded with
instructions to make me in you and
everybody else and everything else right
living organisms have DNA how did this
idea of hey we could put digital data on
there come up when did that happen
and what was the scientific thinking
behind that
so the idea actually dates back from the
60s and it was right after the structure
of DNA
started to be more well understood
people looked at it and scratched their
heads and thought you know it's carrying
information about life why can't it
carry any kind of information so one
could use DNA
that except at that time we didn't have
the technology to fabricate DNA or to
read DNA not reasonable speeds before we
get into the technical weeds why are you
interested in using DNA for storage
what's the premise behind it we're very
excited about DNA for at least three of
its properties the first one is density
so instead of really storing the bits
into devices that we have to manufacture
we are really looking at a molecule
storing data in a molecule itself and so
molecule can be a lot smaller than the
devices were making just to give you an
example you could store the information
today stored in a data center one
exabyte of data into a cubic inch of DNA
so that's quite tiny durability is the
next interesting property of DNA and so
DNA if preserved under the right
conditions can keep for a very long time
which is not necessarily possible with
media that's commercial today I think
the long is commercial media is rated
for 30 years that's tape still tape Wow
DNA if encapsulated in the right
conditions has been shown to survive
thousands of years and so it's very
interesting from our data preservation
perspective as well and then one other
property is that now that we know how to
read DNA and we'll always have the
technology to read it so now we'll have
those readers if we don't have those
readers we have a real problem but we'll
have those readers forever
as long as their civilization so it's
not like floppy disks that are in the
back of a drawer just gathering this
will really have technology to read it
[Music]
so let's get into the technical weeds on
your current work what's the science
behind DNA storage there's a workflow
that starts as I understand with binary
code and then it gets crazy from there
tell us the workflow behind the science
that's right so if we go back to the
structure of DNA it's that chain of the
different phases ATC and G and so the
way to think about them is they're a
sequence of these bases and the way to
think about bits is digital data is
essentially a sequence of bits and so
the science behind it starts with
translating those bits into bases so a
very simple way to think about that is a
corresponds to 0 0 C corresponds to 0 1
G 2 1 0 and T 2 1 1 and so if we have a
sequence of bits we'll take every two
bits and translate it into a base we use
a lot more sophisticated methods but
that's the first step
so that leads to the next question
you've got the binary code translated
into DNA code then what do you do with
it so we know which sequences of DNA we
want now there's a process of
manufacturing the DNA and there's a
process where multiple chemicals are
flowed and the DNA sort of grows right
and so we know which sequences need to
be grown and those sequences are grown
from a surface so once we grow the DNA
we'll remove it from where it was grown
and more encapsulated so encapsulation
can be done in a number of different
ways one of the types of encapsulation
we've been looking at is an
encapsulation developed by ETH Zurich
they were inspired by the fact that DNA
survives in bone and wanted to do
something that had similar properties
but it was easier to handle rather than
having to grow bone and so on what they
developed was a type of chemistry that
will encapsulate the DNA in glass it's
actually silicon dioxide and they
developed nanoparticles that
then the DNA gets attached to and then a
layer of glass is grown around it and so
that keeps it away from water which is
something that degrades the DNA UV light
and when the temperature goes higher it
protects it from really degrading so
what happens if I want to access my data
then let's say I gave you a video and
you say okay I'm gonna put it on DNA and
I'm gonna store it and I say Karen I
want my video back what do you do so
when your video was stored it was stored
in a certain location so it's just
organized in a spatial way right so
there's some way to retrieve the actual
molecules encapsulated the next step is
to dean capsulate them so we need to
remove all that glass that was added for
stability and extract the DNA once
that's done and that's a first part of a
random access process it's a
hierarchical process first you
physically find the smaller set of DNA
molecules you're interested in but then
within that there are many molecules
that may belong to different movies that
you've stored and you're just interested
in one movie you don't want to read the
whole collection right and reading the
whole collection would actually be
wasteful and so we would like the
ability to further select that
particular movie you want to watch and
it turns out that there's a process to
do that we do it chemically and so it's
just another reaction that comes from
nature actually and is repurposed for
this goal for this purpose so the paper
you wrote about it that explains how you
do that can you give us an executive
summary of how you've gone about that
that chemical process the chemical
process is really borrowed from the
biotech industry it's a pretty standard
process called polymerase chain reaction
and it's the process that copies DNA
however you can use it in a way that
will just copy sequences that have a
certain sequence at the end and so we
select the right sequences at the end
and then use an enzyme to do the DNA
copy now that enzyme is selective it
will only copy pieces of DNA that have a
little bit of a double helix and so we
store the DNA as a double helix to do
the process we separate the two sides of
the helix and then only attach a little
tail to each of the signs so that that
tail matches the object that we're
interested in reading okay and so the
enzymes will only copy the sequences
that have that specific tail so we can
select which of the molecules are copied
now the other molecule storing the rest
of the videos are still there but in
much smaller quantity PCR and this
polymerase chain reaction actually
copies the DNA exponentially and so we
can very quickly get to a lot of copies
of the data we're interested in and just
a few copies of other data were not
interested in so that when we sample to
read that information most molecules
were sampling our molecules that were
interested in what's the process of
identifying and molecule the technology
to read DNA a sort of indirect reading
if you will it's in direct observation
of the molecules and so there are a
number of different technologies to do
that some of them use optical solutions
and so they multiplied the molecules and
then make them glow in different in
different colors just based on the
sequences that they are made of there's
another technology that is electronic
and so you drag the DNA true nanopore
it's literally called the nanopore
because it's a pore that's nano sized
and the DNA goes through and it causes
some current disturbances true that
nanopore
that are then read and sensed and then
you can tell what the sequence of DNA is
that's so yeah it really does sound
science fiction but it works
[Music]
so most of us understand megabytes
gigabytes even terabytes because we have
some frame of reference but when we hit
petabyte exabyte zettabyte and i just
read the new one yottabyte 10 to the
24th power it's just mind boggling
territory so here's the funny part in
your research it was big news that you
stored 200 megabytes right strands of
DNA so I think you're well past that now
like around 800 gigabytes but it gives
us some indication of how hard it is to
do what you do I mean to be excited
about 200 megabytes I remember when I
had a 200 megabyte hard drive but that
was in the 80s right yeah so what are
the challenges that researchers face if
200 megabytes is a big deal that
indicates that there's still some
challenges to getting to scale that's
right so the challenges are really
improving those speeds at which we can
read the DNA so we don't need very low
latency we can wait for the information
to come out but for it to be a practical
solution for storage we wanted to give
us a high rate of bytes per second those
rates today are so low and that's why
the 200 megabytes is a big deal is you
know the best we can do with technology
today but just to put it in perspective
just one year or two years earlier in
our lab we were working with 200
kilobytes of data which is a thousand
times smaller and so we've been
experiencing improvements already just
by doing the research all of these
technologies had to go through this
milestone to get to full deployment
today so we're on the way there you're
on track yes back to the challenges
so getting the triplets up is a
challenge and then lowering costs so DNA
manufacturing today is still quite
costly but for both of these challenges
they sort of go hand in hand if you get
the speed up you also get the cost down
we see no fundamental physical reason
why you couldn't really scale it
to the level of being acceptable or
being suitable for a DNA there's storage
so what are the roadblocks then getting
to that speed one of the big roadblocks
is really scaling the structures but
also automating the process so writing
DNA and reading the Etna today is
automated but there are many steps in
between so for example the encapsulation
and the preparation the random access
that we were talking about those are not
automated yet we really need to automate
the whole process so automation for us
is also a big challenge and a big deal
and you're working on that yes we're
working on that as well we've talked
about quite a few factors that make this
more viable and I would imagine since
we're talking about computer science
involved in the biology and systems
science that algorithms play a role here
could you talk a little bit about what's
going on in that arena yes absolutely
so in fact algorithms do play a big role
here and we have fantastic team of
coding theorists working here at
Microsoft Research on this problem and
on the project itself so they developed
algorithms that really reduce the effort
to recover the data from DNA one of the
big contributions there was to encode
the data in a way that once we read it
on the way out we need to process
minimal amounts of information to really
recover the data so that was also a big
contribution in that paper what's the
ultimate goal of DNA storage what's the
aspiration if you succeeded beyond your
wildest dreams what would success look
like to you success would look like
everyone in the world has access to DNA
data storage and so really at Microsoft
our mission is to empower every person
an organization to achieve more with DNA
we would empower every person and
organization to store more maybe they'll
have that as one of the tag lines but
right now where are we in that quest we
are just starting right so
we're looking at really wrapping our
heads around how to build an end-to-end
system that will allow us to achieve
that goal we're first targeting archival
storage applications in the data center
and then we'll see where it goes we
think that that's probably the lowest
lowest resistance path for DNA data
storage and we think that there may be
improvements in the future that will
allow us to target different scenarios
as well so that's interesting because
there are different markets and
different reasons for people storing
things right and so the archival storage
would be more like I don't need this
right away and I can tolerate a gap
versus I need this on my computer
because I have to deliver it to my boss
tomorrow morning how does DNA play in
that realm right now yes so we look at
DNA at least currently or initially as
an archival storage technology and so in
addition to the fact you don't need it
immediately you need to store it for a
long time and hopefully not taking too
much space right so that's what we see
as the great match between the DNA
technology and the needs of archival
storage you were featured in Fast
Company magazine as one of the hundred
most creative people in business in 2016
which is super cool but something in
that write-up caught my eye they
projected that we'd hit 16 zettabytes of
data by 2017 which was last year I
imagine we're past that now
the premise behind all this is that we
need to preserve the world's data my
question then is is everything we're
doing worth preserving
when do we cross the line to being
people on that TV show hoarders or
everyone feels sorry for people who
can't throw anything away and to be
honest I'm kind of like that person
digitally I have 32,000 photos on my
phone well it's in the cloud right let's
be honest I kind of feel like I need
help more than a bigger box yes so there
is a lot of information we don't need to
store even though I'd argue that digital
archaeologists of the future would love
to have access to all you're at 32,000
pictures no they would but but they
would really understand how we live
today
exploration culture exploration that's
right and that's why we still study past
civilizations right we won't understand
how they lived and you know how life was
at that time and learn from that friend
but also you know there are pieces of
data that we are today drawing away that
may be very helpful actually we talked
to customers we talked to different
segments of the market who would like to
store more information I just came back
from a meeting at the Library of
Congress they would love to store more
information if it weren't that expensive
right to do it
I actually love that answer because my
question was real and I think what you
just said is an application or a reason
for exploring this new technology the
bigger question would be how then will
future digital archaeologists sort
through everything to make discoveries
and inferences and things that's a great
question so there's a whole field of
machine learning and AI that's evolving
today there's quite a lot of advances
happening in the field right now they do
help a sort through all the data that
we're generating there's a limit to that
too so that is really I think a question
that we'll have to do a lot more
research to really understand how to
deal with it
I'd say the field of data organization
is also a pretty interesting one if we
already have structure on the data then
we might as well preserve that but we
need storage to preserve that
information as well so talk about the
people you're working with you have some
really interesting partners both
organizationally and individually and
it's bringing some really interesting
diversity to your team that I think
probably benefits both the work and the
industry yes absolutely so the DNA data
storage project at Microsoft we've been
collaborating with University of
Washington since the beginning of the
project and we also work with partners
like twist bioscience and we have a
collaboration with ETH Zurich but
overall since it's such a
multidisciplinary project we need people
with different backgrounds offering the
French perspectives so
have a very diverse team and one of the
interesting things is that once you
start a project like this people are
using different vocabularies and there
is a little more work that goes into
starting to communicate well and as a
team but once that initial obstacle is
overcome things happen so much better
just because people are offering
different perspectives there's a lot of
diversity not only personally but also
how people are thinking and everybody's
learning from each other we have all the
way from coding theories to computer
architects and engineers working on
mechanics and molecular biologists and
so quickly different backgrounds people
from all over the world just working in
in an exciting multidisciplinary project
and learning from each other
that makes it super exciting let's talk
about you for a minute
what car you interested in what you're
doing personally and how did you end up
at Microsoft Research well I am forever
learner I think what led me to get my
PhD was really I didn't want to stop
learning and so I've made it kind of my
profession so that's what led me to keep
pursuing more and more degrees until I
might not have degrees to pursue maybe
an MBA someday but being a researcher
allows me to continue learning and in
fact learning and then putting together
things that I've learned from different
areas and different perspectives into
the same project and as I mentioned
earlier making science fiction into
reality it sort of couldn't be more
exciting so how did you end up at
Microsoft Research how did I end up here
[Laughter]
things are you bump into somebody in an
airport and you know later on they
contact you and say hey I'm forming a
new group at Microsoft would you like to
come interview did that happen that
didn't happen do you remember who you
bumped into yeah it was the manager who
hired me
Microsoft dog burger all right so one of
the frameworks I read about this work in
is an article that talked about how
biotech has benefited tremendously from
the advances or the progress in silicon
technology and in to some degree they
suggested that why we're doing this is
it's time for biotech to give back in
other words for computer scientists to
start putting biomolecules in their
computer architecture so what's next in
the field here what are the exciting
lines of research that emerging
researchers might be interested in one
of the things we're starting to look
into and are really excited about is
once you have stored data into DNA there
is the question of what else can you do
with it as a molecule can you perform
any operations over them but the
molecular level not just selecting them
and then reading them and it turns out
there's a whole field of DNA in
nanotechnology that looks at computing
with these molecules so we even have a
Microsoft Research Cambridge a group
that has looked at bio computation and
so we're starting also to see how we can
use such techniques and the properties
of DNA to perform operations over the
data as its stored in DNA as we close
Karen what would you like people to know
about your research but they might not
know yeah so I think the thing to be
aware is that this is an emerging
technology and we're starting to work
towards really building systems and
wrapping services around it
it will take some time to get there but
I think what's cool is that you know
there's a company like Microsoft who's
really willing to invest and really
think about you know how are we going to
build solutions for the IT industry in
the future and so I'm very happy and
feel very fortunate to be working on
this project
Karen Strauss thank you for joining us
today
thank you
[Music]
to learn more about dr. Karen Strauss
and the biological future of digital
data storage visit
microsoft.com/testlabguides
[Music]